i remember first hearing the phrase
internet meme
and then being kind of annoyed because
people
very clearly thought that an internet
meme was the only kind of meme there is
we think about culture being ears you
know epochs or times within
art and so to actually talk about the
discrete units that exist that are
surrounding us all the time
and how they evolve that was super super
interesting you know all the time i was
thinking god these brands are just going
to tear me apart because of what i'm
doing
but they're so in on the joke and you
have to be
and that's the thing you can't be seen
as going you know no i don't want to be
a part of this this is the world we live
in this is it this is what's going on
around us do you send a lot of memes
i do yeah constantly rather than
communicate like yeah
that's how i communicate yeah and you
can they can just say a lot more than
one sentence as well in some situations
that's true yeah meme is a written
in a written joke here that's related to
something that happens in real life
i think it also links with this ironic
attitude to
everything where you can just express
your you know disdain disappointment
a lack of trust in something so that's
why we call it a universal language
it brings you to this part of like
internet collective so you feel
that a certain community gets you or
maybe you're getting a certain community
i read the selfish gene richard dawkins
back at university and i was really
inspired by the idea that
you could have these units of culture
called a meme that would spread from
person to person so
talking talks about religion being the
ultimate meme how you can have
religion or the idea of god is such an
infectious concept
that you can't not think about it once
you've heard it but then
as it passes from person to person it
evolves to understand memes you need to
understand the concept of a replicator
that is information that is copied with
variation and selection
so genes are a replicator when animals
mate or
seeds grow and so on you have
information that's copied
with variations and huge selection
pressure so most of them die
this is what darwin saw back in in the
origin of species in 1859
the same applies to memes all the
information that we put out all day long
and all the books we read and the radio
programs and tv things we watch and so
on
they're competing for our attention most
of them we forget
most of them nobody bothers to watch and
the very few that succeed and get
millions of people involved are the ones
that we see all around us in the world
same process is happening in biology
with a different mechanism
first of all like it got a bit of
attention and it's but it sort of sat
there for a little bit and
things and i was thinking oh maybe
they're not that funny and then
there was a fashion show in paris the
dior show
and at the time celine dion was like
super hyped so she was over in paris and
everyone was just going crazy for her
and i saw this image over
with this dr bag so i put the celine
logo on top of it and
faked it up to it like it was in gold
posted it
went to bed woke up in the morning to a
complete
tirade of messages on my phone
and dior had reposted it and it just
completely kicked off
when i think of memes i think of them as
synonymous with the idea of creating
bits of culture
and i think the best advertising and the
best design and the best
thinkers behind the best advertising
best design have always gone out to
create bits of culture and that's
mometic
the fact that you've given people this
structure for them to find themselves in
they might not have called it memetic or
called it memes
it's really important to understand what
it means to say
genes are selfish all replicators are
selfish or memes are selfish
what it means is that they will get
copied however and whenever they can
given the opportunity
so when we think about the world of
memes internet memes or every other kind
of memes
we think we're developing them designing
them creating them for our own purposes
when a different way of looking at it is
they are using us
to get themselves ahead in the
competition and
that way of looking at it shows you how
very close to biology it is
and how our role is not to be in charge
and doing it for our own sake
it's all really happening for the sake
of the memes themselves
you